we looked at a bunch of ID's yesterday
and the reason why what are you talking
about yeah even though it's like what
only two lessons in is because data
statistics I feel this is just my
personal sort of vibe from the subject
from this coming is that more than any
other of the parts of the course strains
of course you've done it sees it kind of
like a grade of mismatch of
ideas like what do any of these have to
do with each other and you can kind of
fold this type of learning that we go
through although it's understanding them
but not getting the fact that there are
all connected in these very very
fundamental ways so yesterday we focused
on three main ideas and they all sit
around the idea of questions now can
anyone remind me you can if you can
remember around questions what kinds of
things did we learn about the kinds of
questions you would pose in a survey
under data and statistics we asked three
simple questions about questions do you
want yeah okay so we looked at different
kinds of questions right lots of lots of
different kinds so we said I'm gonna put
it here we said what kinds of things can
you ask what kinds of things can you ask
so we looked at all the different
categories of questions at which there
were many different kinds okay what else
did we talk about with regard to
questions not just what ah good yeah we
did in the second group we talked about
the people right so we talked about who
you're gonna ask in the problems and try
to get an accurate data sit we'll come
back to that in a minute there's one
more thing yeah very good so in terms of
like once you have your questions you
don't either you want to ask that way
you convey those questions there's lots
of different options right and they tend
to be kind of um sort of grouped into
all that ordered in terms of what cost
and practicality okay now just to drill
into these ideas a little further under
this idea of what based on the kinds of
questions you ask on a survey you will
get different kinds of data out of that
and you might recall we drew a funky
looking tree diagram
something like this now we don't have to
rehearse the whole thing but just so
that we can refresh our memory there
were two main categories of types of
data that you would get out of different
kinds of services they don't remember
what they were
okay very good cat a carp categorical
which is basically you know words and
also quantitative which was basically
numbers right
then within categorical and clutter
again we had more sub categories so so I
want to tell me yeah very good so
nominal is just when you've got words
okay and is there order to them
whatsoever like I color versus ordinal
where it's like the quality of a book
you know it's like it's poor decent
quite good brand-new and you can put
them on a scale right say it again so
nominal order and all those people
moving yesterday don't need to copy of
it is that because you have them flop up
tree diagram I just want to refresh your
memory
well I'm just try to remind you of like
I said about this thing like I think
this is just enough of a cue that you
can remember what the bits are hey you
should have this tree you should already
have this written on a quantitative five
numbers okay yeah good it's the kind of
numbers you're dealing with
so you've got like a count of some type
like your carry the number of people the
number of siblings or the number of
whiteboard markers those are separate
numbers right so we call them discrete
quantitative alternately if you're
measuring something counting versus
measuring we call that continuous does
so if you measure a weight or you
measure our height or you measure our
anything basically it can be on a range
right so we had continuous data under
that kind of idea okay very good
so the the pieces of feed is yeah now
let's come back to this food question
because we spent a while under this we
said ideally obviously if you want to
get done you want to get all the data
you want to get a complete set you want
to ask absolutely everyone that your
questions are related to and what's that
called the group of people who ever it's
everyone that your questions are related
it has two words in it who are the
people it's that I think I heard it the
target population right now if you get
the entire target population right you
ask questions to all of them that we
call that a census right but if you only
have like a part of the target
population then we call it a simple okay
and more often than not this is already
resort to god that's really hard to do a
census which is why we only do one every
five years okay so now you have all
these pieces together you might be able
to be able to understand what we're
looking at today three ideas and they
all fit under here because there are
samples and then there are samples so
there are three kinds of samples we're
gonna look at today in the scheme of the
rest of this diagram I'm gonna give you
the a cutest one and then we'll explore
them one at a time then our s and s yes
yes no not air bags I do get find out
what SRS stood for actually stands for
supplemental restraint system as in what
happened to him your seatbelts I don't
know